when relationships start enthusiasm for
our partners is typically natural and
very intense we think of them constantly
we only want to spend more time in their
company we Delight in their many skills
and accomplishments but this early phase
of powerful admiration and longing
rarely lasts
the world often explains this cooling as
just an inevitable result of sheer
exposure it is they say typical to
neglect what or who is always around
true reasons seem more complicated more
psychologically rich and in their own
way a lot more hopeful
if we stop admiring our lovers it is
chiefly for one reason because we are at
some level
Furious anger destroys admiration we
cease to love because we unknowingly
grow entangled in various forms of
unprocessed Fury we can't cheer our
partner on because somewhere deep inside
we grow inhibited by Trace memories of
certain letdowns large and small of
which they've been guilty
perhaps they caused us immense
difficulties around exams and never
apologized maybe they flirted with a
friend of ours and refused to admit to
the fact in a way that left us feeling
tricked and unsure or they might have
booked a holiday without asking us and
then insisted that they'd done nothing
wrong
every little mistake was not on its own
necessarily always particularly serious
but taken together a succession of minor
disappointments can acquire a terrible
capacity to dampen and ultimately
destroy love
yet it's not the simple fact of being
let down that counts very much the true
problem comes about when there hasn't
been an opportunity to process our
disappointment irritation is only ever
toxic when it can't be rapidly and
thoroughly discussed
perhaps we tried to explain what was
wrong but we got nowhere or more subtly
we might have felt unentitled to make a
fuss over so-called small things and
therefore said nothing even though in
our depths the Small Things mattered
immensely to us
with great unfairness to our partner we
may have forgotten to admit to our own
sensitivities even as we developed a
steady burden of resentment on their
account
what follows from such buried anger is
something that can be mistaken for mere
disinterest
we're not so keen on celebrating their
birthday anymore we withhold sexual
attention we don't look up when they
walk in a room
this could seem like the normal impact
of time and familiarity but it is no
such thing it's evidence of cold Fury we
do our anger and honor and start to
dismantle its dangerous impacts when we
can recognize the distinctive
Stranglehold that frustration and anger
can acquire on our emotions we never
simply go off people we only ever get
angry with them and then forget that we
are so
to refine our instinctive enthusiasm for
our partner we need to accurately locate
our suppressed distress we have to allow
ourselves to be legitimately upset about
certain things that have saddened us and
properly raised them for as long as we
need to in a way that lets us feel
acknowledged and valued a good couple
should allow for regular occasions when
each person can without encountering
opposition ask the other to listen to
stories of incidents large or small in
which they felt let down or frustrated
of late it goes without saying that we
might not immediately see why a given
thing should matter so much to our
partner but that isn't the point the
objective of the exercise is just to let
the partner know that we care about
whatever they happen to be concerned
about
to ensure that our desire never suffers
this kind of hygienic ritual might
unfold as often as once or twice a week
if couples too often ignore the
requirement it is because they operate
under an unfair burden of Bravery they
assume that it cannot be seen to want to
make a complaint about things that give
off an impression of being small and so
stay silent about their upsets until
it's simply no longer possible for them
to love
wiser couples know that nothing should
ever be too small to cover at length for
what is ultimately at stake in a
marathon conversation about a single
word or event can be the fate of the
entire relationship
it might not be silly at all to devote
an entire evening to understanding why a
partner got silently immensely upset by
the way we said the word ready to them
at breakfast the day before or was a
little slow at laughing at a mildly
unfunny anecdote about a train in a
suitcase the gratitude that will flow
from such an effort to understand them
will amply be repaid the next time we
feel abandoned because they forgot to
put the lid back on the olives or
omitted to add a second kiss at the end
of an email
to complain in love is a noble and
honorable skill very far from the
whininess with which it is sometimes
confused the irony of well-targeted and
quickly raised complaints is that their
function is very far from negative
honesty is a love-preserving mechanism
that keeps alive all that's impressive
and delightful about our partner in our
eyes by regularly voicing our small
sorrows and minor irritations we are as
it were scraping the Barnacles off the
Keel of our relationship and so ensuring
that we will Sail on with Greater Joy
and admiration into an authentic and
unresentful Future